Thanksgiving all-stars featuring the
grandpa who always finds a way to steer
things back to politics she the size of
the bird this year we can afford more
Turkey thanks to Trump's tax cuts your
brother's nervous new girlfriend who
overcompensates by laughing too loudly
at everything
the older perpetually single
aunt who constantly needs everyone to
know she's a very sexual person speaking
of dark meat did I ever tell you the
story the friend who has a food allergy
to everything on your table Turkey is a
no-go I'm allergic tryptophan cranberry
sauce has citric acid potatoes have
starts and then they would kill me this
role is not gluten-free also I'm
allergic to the plate the priest who may
be banging your mom and I are going
skiing next weekend for a prayer retreat
the Canadian friend who constantly
reminds you this is just American
Thanksgiving yeah we had our
Thanksgiving up in Canada on October
14th right so first but whatever you
know this is fun too
and finally the relative who may be
taking a nap at the table but then again
maybe dead
thank you
the answer there is dead not now